last time i saw you i was staying in
your basement yes you were and i was
telling my roommates that we were doing
this conversation i told them actually
to stop by aj's if they wanted to see
you again they were asking if you're
going to stay in our house right i did i
will say i mean i stayed with you
because there was a housing shortage
issue correct and you generously took me
in but i had a really great time also
your house is ridiculously nice much
nicer than what i was dealing with in
college so yeah we're kind of spoiled as
college kids
but congratulations your editor-in-chief
of the federalist uh how's that going
it's going great we just announced this
a couple weeks ago i've been at the
federalists since we started in 2013
and have loved it and loved seeing what
we've done and very excited to take the
reins here what does
your role as editor-in-chief look like
because my understanding of
editor-in-chief is maybe like when i was
in charge of my school newspaper and i
feel like that's definitely different
for the federalists it actually is
probably the same i think there's like a
an editor's club where no matter what it
is like you know neighborhood newsletter
or large publication you have some of
the same things overseeing
all the other writers and we have you
know staff writers but we also have
quite a few contributors who are on the
outside just making sure we're covering
all the important things that should be
covered and that's particularly
important in our media environment where
so many of the large media outlets are
just completely out to lunch or just
worse
on how they
report or characterize the news
how they shape narratives and it's just
really important to not just fight
against that but but be aggressive in
saying what is actually important that's
going on in the world um in the country
and so it's it's fun but we never lack
for
uh work we're seeing today like such a
divide in the media more of this like
this left and this right kind of
competing against each other
where do you think this kind of began
this divide where we have like
left-leaning media and leaning media so
in this country we actually used to have
extremely partisan media if you read the
newspapers at the time of the founding
and even for a long period after that
they are extremely partisan
they wear their bias on their slaves and
then we had this period of time in the
middle part of the previous century
where we moved to what a lot of people
call the american model of journalism
where you aim toward objectivity and you
have just this like voice of god with a
shared set of facts and then people can
make up their own mind about that shared
set of facts
and that was always more an ideal than
reality and a lot of
liberal advocacy actually got pushed
through this this
model and it's just completely fallen
apart in recent years as everybody with
a pulse understands that the vast
majority of our corporate media has a
hard left not just bias but propaganda
approach to
talking about really important things
you know global pandemics or um you know
international affairs or what's
happening in the country at any given
time and the trust in today's media is
kind of i would say it's not as
trustworthy you noticed that i'm just a
little bit yeah where do you think this
has really come from yeah so um
it is off the charts bad for the for the
corporate media nobody really trusts
them only like even
uh their numbers aren't great among
democrat or leftist readers
they are the only ones who will report
any amount of trust and that is purely a
reflection of the fact that much of the
corporate media exists to advance their
agenda so it's not it's not really
meaningful in any sense um but yeah
they've completely lost the plot in
recent years they went from
some bias
some extreme bias i always think it's
funny that the first republican
president to complain about bias was
dwight eisenhower there's been a long
complaint of the republican party and
conservatives uh but in the last several
years has just become
i mean just they have nothing they are
um there's so much embracing
narrative pushing over reporting of
facts that there's nothing left what is
the difference in reporting a narrative
as opposed to just reporting
truth or facts right so ideally you
would be just
whatever the thing is that you're
writing on you'd be collecting
facts and trying to report them
in a way that matched the scenario
and what we've seen happen with our
corporate media is that they're not
really interested in reporting facts
they're interested in pushing a
narrative they want to push people into
doing something maybe it is accepting
draconian lockdowns as a response to the
global pandemic so rather than just
reporting honestly about what we know
what the rates of infection are what the
rates of transmission are they
worry about how reporting facts might
affect their real goal which is to push
you know lockdowns or to push a shutdown
of the economy or to have a certain
political aim and so they shape
everything to match the narrative rather
than just letting the facts go where
they may and you saw that i mean we've
seen this for years but particularly i
think in response to last couple years
with the with the global pandemic there
was just an open acceptance of
suppressing news for fear of how it
might affect
political goals and that's very
dangerous i mean it's important that
people you know sometimes facts are not
fun to deal with like
you take for example the um
early days of the global pandemic
there was some concern that maybe the
wuhan institute of virology had
something to do with the cobot 19 and
that was suppressed that was like
violently suppressed you couldn't talk
about it and you could even be banned
from social media and it would have been
good to know that that was a logical
line of inquiry for foreign policy
reasons for national security reasons
for health reasons you know who knows
who would have been saved it might have
affected vaccine development and yet it
took like a year for for that to be
allowed to be discussed and that was all
narrative pushing instead of facts and
so when we focus on that narrative you
mentioned that it's like dangerous to
the country
how in what ways is it dangerous in so
many ways because now you think also of
what happened to an entire field public
health professionals which were largely
held in high regard at the time this
started and you know i think people
understand that public health
professionals are like anyone else that
you might believe something to be the
case and later you find out it's not
true
but because of the way that the media
and public health professionals work to
kind of suppress information or to push
narratives i think you've seen a decline
of trust not just in the media but in
the public health profession itself so
you know this has been a very bad
pandemic that we've lived through it's
obviously taken many people's lives it's
injured a lot of people
but it's not the worst thing you could
ever imagine happening
and if there were something else
unleashed upon the world that was even
worse you can imagine that the last
people you might trust would be some of
these same professionals that were so
wrong in the last couple of years do you
think today we value
truth and like fact reporting as opposed
to people who reinforce our opinion yeah
i think it's human nature to want to
have your opinions reinforced i think
studies have shown that people
very much
flock to arguments that support their
already held biases and that's just
something that we all deal with even if
we wish that we didn't and so we can
personally work to combat that
or just make sure that we're not just
accepting things because it's what we
want to believe is true by going out of
our way to seek out other viewpoints and
test our ideas against those viewpoints
and uh and just you know
be well read do you think it's possible
to be completely objective in journalism
or is there always going to be a little
bit of that bias in there so when i was
starting out i was trained in that ideal
that you are aiming toward objectivity
and i think it's a great way to be
trained you have to work really hard to
make sure that you are
looking at other viewpoints including
them
you know questioning your assumptions
and so i think that's important no
matter what type of journalist you are
you should always be thinking what are
the different arguments that are out
there um i'm not a huge believer in the
success of the
of that american model of object aiming
toward objectivity i just saw how it
didn't work and how it was used to kind
of um
i don't know
it was it was something that made people
feel like they were doing something more
than they were actually doing something
but i still kind of prefer it to some of
the corruption that we've seen recently
like i thought
i don't know how much you remember what
was going on in 2015 2016. i was a
freshman in high school
but um so that was the that was the
period where the media just completely
got broken
they had been previously claiming that
they were non-partisan and objective and
with the rise of
the republican presidential primary with
donald trump they just they just
completely broke and they openly
admitted that they felt their job was to
interfere in the election keep him from
being elected you know portray news in
such a way so as to decrease the chances
of him being elected not cover news
stories or come and it just
was
really bad and i thought that
after that effort failed in 2016 that
maybe they would return to this idea of
pushing facts instead of narratives of
not having everybody in the newsroom be
a crazy left winger uh promoting people
who weren't that way firing people who
were that way you know i thought maybe
it would be a big wake-up call and
instead they somehow got worse i mean
2015 2016 was less bad than than the
rest of that administration where they
embraced this crazy conspiracy theory
they pushed it they broke all of their
own journalistic standards to push out
false anonymously sourced stories again
pushing an agenda that was you know not
one that they should have been pushing
and they just seem to be addicted to
failure um and partly because it's
lucrative for them like powerful forces
like
this new model of journalism i mean jeff
bezos bought the washington post it's
it's a good idea for him as one of the
world's wealthiest and most powerful
people to be able to control a major
publication all corporations kind of
feel this way and so they don't care
that they're hurting the country maybe
even hurting the world
it's helping them and their bottom line
and so they
i don't see it changing anytime soon
that's really bad news but yes
great well why did you really get into
journalism where did you first realize
you want to get into journalism was it
because you can see it kind of going
down this path and we need people to
kind of oh combat that yeah it's a good
question that i should probably have a
good answer to but i i guess i was
interested when i was younger like i
think i started
a school newspaper in elementary school
i was yearbook editor for two years in
high school so i was interested in it
but i knew i wanted to become an
economist so i studied economics in
school
and that's the road that i thought i was
going down and then
i don't really know exactly how it
happened except that everybody i knew
who i was friends with they were
journalists and they really liked their
jobs they weren't paid that much but
they really liked their jobs and they
enjoyed that they could you know study
different things and like cover this
topic one day and cover a different
topic the next day and interview people
and i thought that it sounded fun and so
i
made a go for go of it and i i loved it
like the first time i saw my byline i
was covering the
fcc
um
you know like the radio and recording
industry and it was a totally boring
story but it was my first byline and i
was totally hooked and i was like this
is what i'm gonna do where was your
first violin it was a publication called
radio and records oh cool
uh you've always been pretty transparent
about your faith have you seen that
affect your career or your reporting at
all
it's mostly helped i can't i mean i'm
maybe entirely helped yeah so i think
that some lutheran and
we have certain things that just help us
think through how to live our lives like
we have a strong
views on vocation like you serve god by
serving your neighbor and you have
different vocations like you can be a
daughter a wife a mother
an editor and and you have different
roles in each vocation
and as a journalist your job is to serve
others
by telling factual things and you know
bringing people into
a place where they might not have been
able to be before you cover a
congressional hearing or you cover an
event a protest and you get this very
special role
to help other people who couldn't
otherwise know about it and so i like
that i like also um
a commandment that i struggle with is
uh putting the best construction on what
other people are saying you know we we
teach that the commandment against
bearing false witness is much more than
just not lying but that you have to
really put the best construction on what
other people are saying i obviously fail
at that all the time but i like being
reminded of that so that when i you know
when i want to go after someone i think
well what were they trying to say and
can i
articulate that in a fair way and still
critique it but by being
as honest as i can be about what they're
saying do you think your faith has
shaped your conservative values or if
that's led you kind of like down this
political and into your political
beliefs at all my husband and i talk all
the time about how much the last few
years have been very hard for people in
washington dc
and i think that they make politics
their religion it's everything for them
and power is everything for a lot of
people and we
my husband's a journalist also and we
love politics and we're really
interested in it but the
the the core of our lives is in our
church and our faith and and like the
higher things eternal life and so what's
happening in politics is so much less
important than our eternal salvation and
it gives us this this balance and
perspective that i think helps you just
not lose your mind when things are a
little bit in turmoil around you
and um
and that has been extremely helpful for
us and being open about your faith and
then also just talking about politics
you face a lot of criticism how do you
kind of handle that and not bend to what
these people are kind of like saying
about you or forcing you maybe try to do
so
i don't know i i hear that but i think
actually what i what i mostly receive
from people is just a profound amount of
gratitude like if you look in my email
it's just full of people saying really
nice things
and i think it's about who do you want
to be liked by and i remember when we
started the federalists someone said
that we were dangerous because we didn't
want to be liked by the new york times
and i loved that because so many
conservative media people they're
desperate to get hired at the atlantic
they're desperate to get hired at the
new york times i would i don't even
understand why you would want those
things i do care about whether average
americans who i think are
you know the backbone of this country
who have done so much and never get
represented in the media i care what
they think so i i like who likes me and
i also like who doesn't like me i
understand and i feel like the people
that you're looking to like you those
people that you talk about like the
backbone of america what's the best way
for like the average citizen to stay
informed in today's political world yeah
i think it takes a lot of effort it
probably always took a lot of effort but
now because of what we were talking
about with the credibility of the media
being at an all-time low people are
aware that they can't trust some of the
news sources that they've trusted
previously and so i think it's just
important to still get a wide you know
wide variety of inputs and make your do
as much original
viewing of things as you can like one
thing that's great about the internet
and everybody being the reporter is you
can you can kind of like watch a video
of a hearing yourself or you can
read an original document yourself and
make up your own mind about it and so
for me personally what i like to read
like the only
real big corporate media that i
read every day is the wall street
journal i still like it it's not perfect
but i like it
um and then i use real clear politics
which is a web site that kind of covers
things from left center and right kind
of puts the best arguments forward from
all perspectives and it updates
regularly throughout the day so i love
that and then i have like a highly
curated
uh social media feed where people i
trust i follow and so i think that's
that's a good thing um find a voice you
trust find a voice who's told difficult
truths you know and just
maybe keep listening to them unless they
give you a reason to stop
speaking of like biases you've
interviewed all types of people
do you prefer to interview someone who
maybe agrees with you politically or
somebody who you kind of oppose in a
political way
it's easier to interview people who you
oppose so i would prefer that your
questions just come naturally when
you're thinking like
you know they give you an answer and you
just instinctively think why that was a
wrong answer so you can kind of navigate
it better it's harder to do when you
agree with someone on the other hand
when someone is you know
more aligned with you you kind of can
dig deeper in certain ways to flesh out
what's going on but i'm not the world's
uh best interviewer i've admitted that
before but i've gotten to interview
really high-level people
and it's you know it's always
it's always interesting um
but i find it like you have to have a
balance between going after the
information that you came to get
you know you're usually there for a
reason but also letting the person that
you're interviewing kind of have a say
in what they're gonna what they're gonna
talk about um
you know i don't like just a completely
belligerent interview i wanna hear i
wanna really come to understand what it
is that yeah that they're thinking well
you say you're not the best interviewer
but it's like not every day that i get
to ask you for interviewing interviewing
tips
how do you prepare for an interview
so i have interviewed i mean it's funny
like i've done so many interviews now
that usually i just think about what it
is that my
my my near goal is which is a story
where i probably have a pretty good idea
of what it is that i want to find out
and uh and just and just i plot it out
i practice like what i'm gonna what i'm
gonna ask but i also think like if you
can interview in person that is so much
better than over the phone and during
covid times i've had to do so much over
the phone and you can't get a feel for
what how comfortable someone is or you
know when you're in person you can feel
like do they want to go deeper here do
they want to
you know did they pause in a weird way
and look a certain direction so that you
know that they're thinking about
something that you want to interrogate
um but i like to also just you know if
you can interview someone in their
office or in their home i love that
because you get
little cues about what's important to
them um and you just can be more
comfortable with them
um by talking about like oh i see that
sports jersey
what's that about the non-verbals yeah
they're important well and just kind of
treat people as people right without um
without having to just be there for
business
but i think just as much research as you
can do beforehand so that you're not
wasting time
and i don't know
so you've interviewed president trump
who he's pretty high profile
do you have like a best trump story from
like that interview so i just want to
first say that he is the most difficult
person in the world to interview i'd
imagine yeah i mean
he's like
you you ask him a question here and he
goes all the way around before getting
you know and you're kind of trying to
bring him back to the thing why do you
think he does that
i don't know he's a really interesting
cat i also think it's weird because he's
much nicer in person than he is uh like
on tv he comes off like a total
yeah no i understand antagonistic guy
but then when you're in person with him
he's usually
just i don't know he's much uh much more
gentle i talked to this one reporter who
said that most
most politicians
in public they're kissing babies and
they're complimenting your wife and then
in private they're just jerks and then
trump is the one who will insult your
wife and like attack the baby but then
in private being like really nice um
sorry but what was your question about
oh best trump story i don't know um
he's just just from the interview
perspective one thing that's interesting
is he'll he has his own rules so you
know in journalism you say um this is on
the record or it's
uh on background on background so on the
record means you can use it totally and
quote the person
on background means you can use the
information but you can't tie it to the
person that you're talking to and then
off the record means it's more like for
your own context you're not supposed to
use it and then people come up with
other things they're funny like deep
background which is like i really mean
don't tie my name to it but he'll say
stuff like this is off the record but
you can use it
you're like what does that mean but in a
weird way like the more you're around
him the more you understand exactly what
he means he means that more like his
background
i think
i hope it hasn't been a problem yet thus
far but um so i've interviewed him in
the oval office i've interviewed him
elsewhere in the white house i've
interviewed him at mar-a-lago several
times and he's just you know like i said
you need a much more tenacious
interviewer than i am to have like a
fully productive thing but i've spent a
lot of time with him and i find him to
be
truly
fascinating
um he did teach me how to take a picture
which i think is funny um
after one of my interviews at mar-a-lago
for my book on the 2020 election
i had realized like i'd never taken a
picture of him even though i'd be you
know i never had like
i'd had many opportunities but i'd never
done it and so we're walking out of his
place and i said well you know can i
take a picture of you and say why don't
we take one together and and so uh
we take a picture and his assistant
shows him the picture and he says i
don't like her and i don't like me
and he's like let's move over here so we
move over to this other location we take
it and she shows him and he says
i like me i still don't like her
and he's he's like i'm gonna teach you
how to take a picture
and he gave me all these tips like you
you look at what the background is not
just the people who are in the picture
he's like so we want to have the
background be
this beautiful mar-a-lago estate you
know with the grass the green grass
below us whatever and then he was
teaching me things like to turn to the
side and put my hand on my hip and like
put my chin out and so we take the
picture oh and he says you can trust me
my wife's a supermodel
was like
i am aware that your wife is a
supermodel yes and um and so
his assistant shows him the picture and
he kind of pauses and he says
well there you go
and it was better
you know what i was thinking how am i my
age and none of my female friends ever
taught me how to take a picture fair
enough and the former president of the
united states is teaching me like really
excellent tips on taking pictures like
it just
was one of those like absurd moments but
was really funny and so now
i'm still not great at taking pictures
but every time i you know when someone
does it i'm like okay wait hold on what
did what did okay
do you think interviewing different
people like that would be maybe the part
you like the best about your job or i
guess what would be the favorite part
about it i don't know i will say so of
all the people i've i've loved
interviewing presidents i've had a few
former president or current or former
presidents um
senators i enjoy senators but i really
enjoy
interviewing um judges
and justices i think because they don't
talk that much to the media
they are very
logical in their thinking
um
it's just interesting i'm just that's
the thing i've enjoyed most is covering
federal judges or other judges and just
getting a better understanding of their
thinking i think because i'm personally
quite interested in the law so yeah when
i first met you last spring you came to
my advanced writing class the first
thing i look is like does she have a
wedding ring um because i'm interested
in knowing how do you balance kind of
like having a family and
a high-profile journalism career
poorly no
so my husband is
the main person who got me into
journalism we were friends at the time
that i followed him into journalism and
he's taught me
everything i know he's with me on
everything and so even to the extent
that i would love to not be
working so much and he's always the one
encouraging me to get out there and do
things having someone who's fully
supportive and a partner is really key
having
a clear understanding of what's most
important so
we both work from home so we're both
very involved in our children's lives
we're very involved in our church and so
it's just like natural balance provided
by just having people who love you and
are with you no matter what's going on
politically i mean even the fact that
they're people i go to church with who
are wildly different political
viewpoints and we all love each other
and we all work together and we're you
know doing the oktoberfest together or
in the in the church choir together and
it just reminds you of what's actually
important versus what people in dc think
is important and this kind of builds off
of that in a way do you have advice for
young people who are looking to go into
a career in journalism
i mean that's that's a broad question
i don't know can you narrow it down a
little bit yeah sure okay i'm gonna be
graduating in may
i'm 21 years old and i ultimately would
like to be in dc um and i want to be a
journalist coming out of hillsdale what
would be i guess
a main takeaway for me as i'm graduating
and going out into that world yeah so i
think it's really weird because when i
started in journalism it was a
completely different path you had i mean
it was kind of standard you start out at
a local paper like even if you wanted to
do tv journalism you started a local tv
outlet and then you slowly worked your
way up into the bigger markets or you
figured out what your beat was going to
be and then you just like drilled into
that you know if you knew you wanted to
be a tech reporter for the rest of your
life you could just kind of work your
way up that way and in the last 20 years
everything's kind of fallen apart
there aren't many local media outlets so
there aren't like good ways to start
local and then get bigger i mean you can
still but it's just
so many fewer opportunities on that
front but then so many more
opportunities in dc and new york with um
outlets that have particular
perspectives and so i think just kind of
accepting the reality that that's that's
where we are now like there's there's no
mainstream journalism anymore that's
just gone it's all
left or right and that's just the fact
and some people like to claim that
they're mainstream they're not they're
left
and um just understanding like what it
would mean if you were to go into a left
media outlet and what it would be like
or to go into a right media outlet and
um so i think that's one thing just
understanding the reality of the of the
environment and then the other thing i
think is just like experiences
everything and don't worry about making
a huge splash right away until you
really know
have like mastered the writing or
mastered being on tv and then you can
kind of like get a feel for everything
and then go for for a big um
everyone's different some people can
make a splash right away but i think
that i've seen a lot of people really
want to share their opinions
very quickly out of college and you know
if you're a hillsdale educated person
you have well-formed opinions i get it
but there's something to be said for
just humbling yourself to the idea
that other people might have something
to teach you for the next several years
and just learning the craft learning the
trade and then going for it
so yesterday you emailed me and we were
kind of you're asking me we're preparing
for this i guess and i asked you what
you were wearing you suggested to me i
never answered like a softball t-shirt
that we should wear softballs t-shirts i
got you a softball shirt oh since i am
on the softball team so i do this is
like awesome if you come back on campus
yeah you will we should just put them on
right now
i love it
great i did want to give you that right
so this is your softball team this is my
softball team we actually i head to
texas tomorrow nice why we're doing this
today yeah well thanks for making time i
really appreciate it this is awesome
it's wonderful to get to hang out with
you i have two requests yes would you
mind signing my rigged book
um
and then of course also could we get a
photo that's like my that's more of my
parents request they were like can you i
know that's cool that you don't want a
photo with me but no i do but like
[Music]
you